I keep starting budgets and don't know
how to stick to them and then they kind
of fall apart life happens keep hitting
this brick wall of you're overqualified
and don't have enough experience in
stuff like grocery or you know trying to
pick up extra shifts at like a local
restaurant doing server work or that
kind of stuff so I I don't know how
they're saying you're overqualified when
you try to get that extra jobs I see
I've had a McDonald's tell me face to
face yeah you're way over qualified to
ever work here do you tell them hey this
is not my be all end all I'm just trying
to make some extra cash um I have told
some yes in both of the scenarios you
just painted you've you've kind of
cornered yourself as this is this tragic
victim in this story and you owe a whole
bunch of money and you're running up
against some roadblocks but I want you
to You' got to change your psychology on
this or it's just always going to be too
heavy